now as we've been hearing the US Senate
and House intelligence committees have
found no evidence for Donald Trump's
claimed that Barack Obama wiretapped
trump tower during the election campaign
but in an interview with Fox News the
president insisted that the substance
behind his allegations would be
presented in due course submitting
certain things and I will be perhaps
speaking about this next week but it's
right now before the committee and I
think I want to leave it to have a lot
of confidence why not wait to tweet
about it until you can prove it because
you Cal you well your words when you
can't provide that because the New York
Times wrote about it not that I respect
the New York Times i call it the failing
new york times but they did write on
january granted using the word wiretap I
was joined now by the national security
analyst Irish aramesh who's in Houston
in Texas hello to you Irish thank you
for joining us here on Sky News so the
intelligence committees say they found
no evidence is it likely that the
president has any that they would have
missed by the way I'd like you to know
and to note that this is the Republican
majority house and a Republican majority
Senate so the House Intelligence
Committee it's led by Congressman Nunez
and it was a Republican a staunch
Republican and the ranking member is
Democrat Adam Schiff from California
from from from Southern California so if
a republican committee chair and a
democratic ranking member colleague are
saying that there is no evidence that
former President Barack Obama wiretaps
president Trump or at the time candidate
Trump or the trump building or what have
you there is really no evidence for
these empty allegations and accusations
that are coming from president Trump my
guess is as good as yours with most
likely president Trump was probably
watching Fox News or another network or
was watching or reading something online
and went out and said these things and I
the best explanation I've heard so far
from those in the business is that
perhaps when some of peeps some people
and its campaign or communicating with
the Russians and the Russians were being
surveilled some of those communications
were picked up but
President as you know has his own style
and make certain claims on Twitter or
off Twitter went out and set that
President Obama wiretap his calls and
his villain which is just completely
baseless and it's not true well you say
really is causing a rift within the
Republican Party itself isn't it how
damaging could that be for the Trump
administration you know that's a very
good point from the very moment let me
just back up a little bit from the
moment that Trump decided to run back in
jun 6 2015 it created a rift within the
Republican Party and we all you know
wrote him off we said there's no way
he's going to survive the primary he did
we said there's no way he's going to
survive the campaign he did we thought
he was going to drop house for one
scandal or another he didn't drop out
and we thought he was going to lose you
know another you know in the landslide
Hillary Clinton even though he lost the
popular vote he still won the electoral
votes and became president so he has
been able to defy all up I given that
but he's gay he's always had problems
with the Republican establishment but
you got to look at look we get a look at
this into what's up into sort of through
the prism of contemporary American
politics that Trump is not really
representing the Republican Party he
represents a populist movement that has
a lot of you know blue color Democrats
and Blue Dog Democrats joining him with
his anti-immigration message what is
populist protection it economic message
what is anti-muslim message and a lot of
sort of dog whistle messages that come
through and resonates a particular part
of his base so that the fact that he is
now alienating the key you know key
members of the intelligence committees
who happen to be Republicans or Speaker
of the House Paul Ryan who's now been
thrown under the bus over the new health
care bill it doesn't really mean that
the president is going to back down as
he said before and that statement still
happens to be true he says if you were
to shoot someone on Fifth Avenue his
loyal supporters would still support him
what's really going to change the
equation is
wait and is one is low of supporters are
going to see that is economic message is
economic policy is anti immigration and
anti you know sort of his isolationist
policies are actually going to view them
harm and are going to hit them into
pocketbooks maybe then they will come
around and they will see that president
Trump's policies are not exactly helping
the middle class so Irish if he doesn't
produce any evidence what are the
implications will there be any
consequences for him we'll have to see
you know we're so far he's been a Teflon
candidate and a Teflon president there
has been some consequences you know he
has to let go of general michael Flynn a
very loyal supporter of his which
michael Flynn with his national security
advisor michael Flynn with a lifelong
Democrat was the director of the Defense
Intelligence Agency was fired by
President Obama but again we all
remember general Flynn and his staunch
supporters throughout the campaign and
even if their national republican the
Republican National Convention you was
the one who changes you know loss or up
and chances you know all those sort of
angry slogans against radical Islamic
extremism xelement so forth but he has
to resign when his times the Russians
were revealed and when it turned out
he'd actually lies to the vice president
my pen question is how costly is it
going to be for the president we know
one thing for sure throughout his
business engagements the past 30
some-odd years and now it is political
life president Trump and before that
candidate and businessmen Trump is very
comfortable with throwing people under
the bus we'll see if he's going to throw
another loyalists from somebody else
because of bit under the bus or whether
this is actually going to cost them
anything but I really doubt is going to
come back and apologize to President
Obama for having made such empty
baseless accusations that he had
wiretaps or he has wires at the trump
building wire pass Trump himself all
right Irish we'll have to wait and see
how this all plays out thank you for
joining us here on sky knees